I'm going to divide the presentation
three parts first parts going to be this
one physical interpretation second one's
going to be the slit experiment then I'm
going to need into colorization okay
that's what we're gonna do today and so
here we have this is the physical
interpretation what is it and this one
won't be covered I'm saying in physics
is about providing a physical
interpretation okay a physical
interpretation requires an object these
are the arguments that I'm going to make
mathematical physics does not provide
physical interpretation to any to any
phenomena in which an invisible entity
is services of a mediator and finally
I'm going to give it an example which is
magnetism essentially two magnets how
they work okay and I'm going to show
that this magnetic attraction /
repulsion can be explained with another
model my rope model and it cannot be
explained by quantum mechanics you know
that was they do not have a physical
interpretation for this we need to know
what is a physical interpretation okay
so let's go on we have to start what is
physics okay what what we intend with
when we say physics what we're referring
to what you're referring to equations
math numbers what we mean
related and so the first place to start
is here where you know you look for
definitions what what are the formal
definitions out there one of them comes
from the Wikipedia the purpose of
physics is to what understand how the
universe behaves sounds straightforward
the problem is the word how we're held
up they're very misleading
are we talking about the description of
how something works you know here here I
have maybe a pen here right I let it go
right and falls to the paper and you say
well how did it fell well it fell at 9.8
meters per second squared
yeah that's that's how it fell in other
words mathematical description you still
haven't told me why you know the cause
what cause what the met
business and and again we also have a
problem the word why because why people
confuse purpose reason with cause and
mechanism causing mechanism belong to
physics
reason and purpose I call that
philosophy ok so so these words are very
critical because some you say how would
someone understand something else ok so
be careful about the word how anyway
it's physics 7 1 there this is from the
Random House dictionary physics the
science that deals with matter energy
motion and force those physics deal with
energy does physics deal with force
these are words of mathematics and I'm
going to argue today they have nothing
that they know to do with physics ok I'm
not here to convince you I'm here to
argue my case I'm in a court of law here
and you're gonna reach whatever
conclusions you want all I'm saying this
is gonna be my art ok the Institute of
Physics I'll be very important Institute
clarifies that this means that's what it
means right physics is about asking
fundamental questions ok I like that and
trying to answer them by observing an
experiment and I'm saying physics has
nothing to do with experiments or ups or
observations and you know I'll prove it
to you man
I dropped a pen right I can do an
experiment what a hundred times you want
a million times whatever number in terms
you want okay so I drop the pen I did
the experiment I repeatable experiment
and I made an observation is that
physics or is physics understanding yeah
let me let me make another experiment
I'll move my eye on ok
is that physics just saying ok here's a
phenomenon and you know I can move my
arm and here's an observation I'm
watching it I'm seeing it I talked him a
ton
to measure put a number is that physics
or is physics understanding what causes
my arm to move and this is what I'm
gonna try to separate one from the other
and they have a couple questions here
one is how did the universe begins which
I didn't like the other ones
how will the universe change in the
future is this what physics does talk
about the universe having what physics
doesn't know about the universe having a
beginning was there a beginning to the
universe is this a valid question are we
talking about you know Bible here in the
beginning and then how will it change in
the future is this part of physics are
we interested in what's going to happen
in the future is this element of physics
and I'm saying these two first ones that
come out of the IOP have very little bit
of anything to do with you know with
physics and here the Canon Academy they
they also say what what do physicists do
what do they do for a living everybody
wonders this you know these guys are
sitting in Canberra at Cambridge Harvard
what are you thinking physics department
yeah what did they do all day just fool
around with equations right on the black
what do they do and this is what they
say you know and this is a very
important site on the internet says
precisely define the most fundamental
are measurable quantities in the
universe okay
and a second one find relationships
between those fundamental measured
quantities is what physics is about
quantities just numbers again we're
described we're saying how but from this
description point of view one not saying
how from a an explanation point of view
we still don't understand what the
mechanism is by following this if this
is what businesses do they're not
physicists yeah that's not be my
argument okay
yeah you don't have to agree with me I'm
just saying this one I'm gonna put forth
okay am i doing physics when I ask these
questions and here you have one by what
mechanism
does a magnet attract another is this an
issue of physics the physics deal with
this issue at all what causes a spoon to
fall the floor rather into the ceiling
do you think it's a question of physics
I mean I think it is now I don't know
about you but you've got to think about
this right what is electricity what is
happening inside of life you know you
got a wire you touch it and what you
don't want to touch it but if you do
touch it you know maybe you don't have
to worry anymore about physics something
happened there right okay is this a
question of physics what causes starts
at the edge of the galaxy to travel
faster or just as fast as those near the
center these are questions of physics
but none of the previous definitions you
know address this that's the same we're
going to quantify it we're going to give
you a quantity so I don't have a
mechanism why have as a quantum number
an equation that's a description okay
the Khan Academy says at the end says to
be honest it's really difficult to
define exactly what physics is I love
that one like we don't have a slightest
cool or doing this excuse changing and
yes physics does keep changing but in
the wrong direction if we're going to
follow what these people have done in
the 20th century Max Born said in a book
he wrote in the 60s he said physics has
become more abstract
well abstract is the opposite of
physical so don't call it physics if you
can do abstractions called abstraction
Department of abstractions I think you
should call it not Department of Physics
what a science science rational
explanations that's what science is you
have to explain a phenomenon rationally
I always give the example of magician
that's the lady in half two pieces
curtains closed curtains open lady comes
out in one piece so what is physics what
is math well the mathematician would
tell you well he could heard in so many
strokes ten strokes one stroke per
second she had two pieces now she's in
one that's that's the number that's
equations that's
just quantities no I want to know how
how the magician did the trick that's
physics so we have two words they're
rational and explanations it's all we
have to do is know what an explanation
is what a rash what rational means and
let's go with explanations first here we
have explained or explanation
illustration of the causes and
mechanisms that underlie the phenomenon
that's fit
that's what physics does what does
mathematics do it just describes an
equation that synthesizes how an object
behaved you can say you know lion ran
and 60 miles per hour
okay that's just a description you still
haven't explained anything wet with that
number with that equation whatever you
put forth
okay here's what rational is I usually
take it in reverse and say I tried to
define what irrational is and my son
corrected me some time ago says well you
don't want to call people irrational
because they get upset and so we don't
you know we try to be impersonal we say
look what we have to say here is the
theory is rational
I'm sorry if you take it personally okay
so the main one converting a concept
into an object you converted concepts
such as love you treat it as a physical
object now you begin to move it around
you forget you know that you were
dealing with a concept so you take
energy and you say I transferred an
energy what do you mean you transfer
energy what did you try an energy is a
concept in fact it's an undefined
concept because nobody hasn't been able
to find what energy is the concept but
you're gonna transfer this I mean I can
try to repent to you I need transfer a
dog to you a tree whatever but cannot
transfer a concept and so that's the
main one converting a concept into an
object and then treating it as an object
and moving it around that's the first
7-1 used your words inconsistently you
don't define your terms or even or
whatever you define you use them and
consistently throughout your
presentation a very famous case the word
point the word point is defined usually
as you know they said what is the point
and the guy said what here it is you
know you puts a dot on the board say
okay here we have a little dot in my
okay that's a point I mean we understand
that
and see it and that the guy never uses
that and he always uses oh yeah I see we
have all these locations or all these
numbers
what are you numbers I thought you were
I thought it was a dot well yeah but
that's funny to represent the point it's
it's a pictorial representation of a
point then what is the point I mean if
that's the pictorial I don't care I want
to know what the point is and the point
is gonna be used as a number or as a you
know as a location then we have a
conflict there because he's not using
these terms in consistent theory doesn't
fall from the assumptions I think the
example you know the prosecutor presents
a knife and then he his theory is about
you know poison you know how the person
was poisoned you know one does it fall
from the other describe and pretend to
explain you know fishy magnetism I'm
going to cover in a minute people tend
to say oh I don't know a magnet works
okay how does it work what do you have
all these domains etc and you have all
these electrons that move in each magnet
okay so the electrons are moving around
they're spinning around the same
direction okay so where you describe you
haven't told me how the spinning of one
electron pulls on the spinning of
another another here I have situation D
balls let's consider these electrons so
this one's spinning and this one spin
fine this one's on this magnet this
one's on the other the other man what's
the mechanism of attraction this is
usually how does this one attract that
don't tell me they're spinning that's a
description fine okay there's many and
what is the mechanism of traction and
they don't have that and also the last
one formulate cause and mechanism in
terms of reasons and purpose why is
there something rather than nothing
that's a question that doesn't pertain
to physics not if it's formulated in the
form in in a way that says why did God
make something rather nothing why did
God make the speed of light 300,000
kilometers per second I don't know he
had
I don't know I mean you know there's
that's a reason that's a question of
purpose
not a question of what is the cause what
is the physical mechanism so those are
two different things and again we tend
to confuse these and think that
mathematically presents physics of
Lights Versailles about the case okay so
here's my definition visit rational
explanations of causes and Nicolas
that's what physics is about and if
we're going to explain we're gonna have
to use objects as far as I know you
cannot do physics without objects if we
bring God in good old man then he wipes
all the matter of the universe
no more matter what physics is going on
what are we seeing what's happening
there's nothing in the only way you can
have a phenomena happen it with objects
it's as simple as that
here we have the researchers someone who
carries out experiments verifies what
others have observed brainstorms
explanations does calculations makes
predictions or intelligent guesses
observed phenomena and verifies is
hunches okay that's a that's our
researcher researcher is a detective
seeking clues to the workings of the
universe that's right and that's a noble
you know job you go to your basement I
want to know about this I'm gonna run an
experiment you can do anything you want
but that's not a physicist that's not a
scientist the scientist that the guy who
comes to the conference and gives you an
explanation of something or how it works
a mechanism that you can bite your teeth
into doesn't mean you have to believe it
just mean now you understand what this
guy has going through this mine that's
all it is
and this and that's what I'm saying the
theory is the physicist right this is
the real scientist an individual who
communicates how something happened the
purpose of a physicist is not to
persuade convince comfort and recruit
I'm not here you to twist your arms I'm
here to give you something objectively
that you can take home and say okay now
I know another version of how this
universe works doesn't mean you're gonna
believe it I can bring angels and say
look you know
the statements with angels okay I know
what's going through your mind see watch
how you're explaining it doesn't mean
you have to believe it okay and yeah
well it does the test of our businesses
is to explain your mechanism objectively
so that the listener visualizes what
caused the event to occur yeah
physicist is a movie director you should
be able to make a movie if you're a
visitor should be able to make a movie
of your theory put it on board for
people to watch and understand the
mechanism just by watching the movie and
you know you want to know how a car
works well you know you can put that in
images you can see them go here's the
tank here's the tube that takes the gas
to the front of the car it goes through
the carburetor that said right cetera
you know and this is how it moves the
wheels you can move you can put all
these parts in a movie and more or less
you know give some background
information and the guy can understand
how a car works well that we do the same
thing with invisible entities you say
well do you have two men it's one of
nandana trucks the other one here very
simple more what's simpler than a car
for that matter so how did it do it what
kind of magic does it do it with well
you have to fill in the blanks you have
to put something in between those two
magnets otherwise you're using magic
you're putting spirits in okay and so
that's what a business is does he makes
the invisible visible suddenly you can
see what you could not see before and
you know without me we do a little trick
thinking to do with this I'm gonna do a
magic trick let's go blow your mind away
never happened before you for the first
time in in human history you know now
between my mouth and the paper did you
see anything happen did you see anything
you know and and the issue is that we do
not we are not able to see everything
that doesn't mean that there's nothing
in there okay and the way we simulate
this is by putting particles you know we
say well this is made out of oxygen okay
what is that object some molecule what
is it Molly it was made out of you know
atoms
okay and so on and so forth but you
always have a physical life some little
ball that here that you can't see but
you can imagine
see what you're saying but to say that
there's absolutely nothing between two
magnets and you're putting spirits
you're putting magic in there you must
put something between two magnets
otherwise you have not explained the
mechanism okay and I rather know the
principle physics requires an object and
a simple principle is so profound that
really should blow you away if you
really understand you
thou shalt not do physics without an
object you can't do physics without an
absence
what would better be happy so if there
is something bringing two magnets
together there's something there we're
going to call that an object it's
something that has saved something
that's in there you know and that is
producing this effect we just don't see
it just like we couldn't see the air but
something is in there yeah okay so now
everybody knows what an object is right
well not really in 10,000 years no one
has defined what an object is at least
for the purposes of physics and here's
the mathematical first okay
they don't look at object they say well
we're interested in physical quantities
whatever that can't possibly and says is
a physical property etc etc and say okay
so what is a physical property well any
property I love that because they
defined a physical property as a
property these are synonym but he says
that is measurable okay something that
is mentioned anything they want to put a
number then they want to put meters or
whatever it's something that is measured
or pounds or whatever in physics a
physical system is a portion of the
physical universe chosen for analysis so
you take a chunk of the universe and
examine on that analysis and that's
going to be a physical system what's in
there physical quantities what is a
physical quantity is a physical property
everybody understood perfectly okay
that's that's the way it works that's
just a bunch of words that they created
it doesn't really take you to the bottom
of it and they finally end up they say
well in physics a physical body this is
a front
websites by the way physical body or
physical object right listen to this is
an identifiable collection of matter
what they're saying is you take a bag
full of marbles and all those marbles
constitute a physical object
that's what they're saying an object a
dog is not a dog he's just a bunch of
atoms okay same for a tree or whatever
which may be constrained maybe it's like
maybe you know it's like a second dairy
issue may be constrained by an
identifiable boundary so some objects
have boundaries some don't so it may be
cancer obviously they haven't thought
about this very long and it can move
essentially right so if the object has
bunch of marbles and it's constrained by
some kind of you know skin and it moves
now we have enough easy okay and I'm
saying these are the really big criteria
that you can take down of all that you
can say look if you look up about the
word object in the dictionary they say
it's seein touch anything that you can
see or touch okay other people have come
to me with the fact that it's a volume
others say it's a mass whatever has mass
others say that which can move and what
we just heard you know what it's made
out of and I'm saying none of those are
valid definition scientific definition
an object is that which has shape stands
alone that's what I'm gonna use today
that definition okay we have to
distinguish it from what a concept is
concept is different than an object
first because it doesn't have shape
that's the person but that's just a like
a rule of thumb to be able to say okay I
think every word in the dictionary if it
has shape I'll put it under objects if
it doesn't have shape I'll put it under
concepts but otherwise it says the word
that includes or embodies two objects
every concept that you can think of has
embodied in it at least two objects why
is it so the word concept is a
relationship between two it's a
relationship okay okay here we have a
word energy is energy of an object or a
content
why do you use in mathematics and here
you have you know all this now the smoke
going on is that energy well you know we
have mr. I don't wanna put words in
anybody's mouth I'll just use richer
fragments words he says it is important
to realize in physics today we have no
knowledge of what energy is so they have
no idea what energy is but everybody
uses this word and that makes you stop
and think you know this is a very
important word in investing in
mathematical physics mass here we have a
couple guys at Edwin Taylor and John
Wheeler done wheelers very famous guy
and at least many people know and he was
he was student by the way of richard
fineman and nature does not offer us any
concept as the amount of matter which is
what we're taught in high school you've
got a scale you high spoon they say
matter what what is mass that's the
amount of matter okay you know it's like
you count marble together and then here
these guys says you know when you get to
college we're gonna tell you the
opposite it's not the amount of matter
in fact there's two kinds of mass one is
inertial mass you know when at
relativistic mass the inertial mass has
to do with the quantity of matter
supposed to when they use it in this
context and in another context they're
going to use something else they which
is how fast you speed up something you
know you speed up the other end you've
got more mass and it came out of the
speed not of the amount of matter okay
so they don't have any idea they just
use these two concepts okay
time when it's time well we don't have
any idea what time is according to the
NHD and the definition of time is the
designation of an instant on the
selected time scale what is the time
scale and agreed-upon system for keeping
time episode we made portal circle
that's how these things work okay well
it's time we don't know of course you
don't know because you haven't defined
it that's why you don't know but all of
these are concepts but the main concept
I wanna deal with today because I'm
going to be giving you an example
magnetic fields is the word field and
here we have all kinds of fields okay
the electric field and we have the
magnetic field if we have the
gravitational field nearly all these
nice fields that we've invented so what
is a field well there you have a whole
bunch of vectors those are those arrows
are not Indian arrows they're vectors
and they have magnitude and direction
that's what a vector is magnitude and
direction and you come out of that
center point that Center Point is
something real so that little like in
the first drawing out of the blue one
and the red one next thing those are
like heads of some something okay some
some little electrical head so that is
tangible that is a real logic everything
that comes out of it are just vectors
and what is a vector vector means that
it decreases as it gets farther away
from the source okay so you get the
magnetic field farther away from magnet
it gets weaker you get an electric field
farther away from you no electric it
gets weaker you get gravitational field
farther away from in this case the
planet it gets weaker that's what the
word field means that there is a region
around a physical object that extends to
infinity and all you can do is give
values along each path along a vector so
if you draw a straight line from the
center of the earth out to the edge of
space time or whatever the edge of the
universe is all they say is the field
extends all the way there but ever
weaker weaker weaker and weaker
that's all field is just a bunch of
numbers that get weaker away from a
source that's a concept field in physics
is a term for region that's why it's a
region around an object okay and that's
under the influence of some force that
can act on matter within the region okay
so all you have is you have something
else coming close to that region and
it's influenced by this invisible
unknown thing called a field that's what
it is but then if you look at the
definition field is a region of space
you look up the word region instead of a
portion of space and you look up the
word space is the infinite extension of
field so you know the full circle there
that's what it we have no real
definitions for these words but the
important thing is that field is a
constant
and questions whether there exists like
in case of magnets a standalone field I
mean we can all recognize what a field
is when you have a magnet you say okay
you know I had sprinkled some iron
filings there and then you know gives
you the shape of the so-called field
fine
can we have the field without the magnet
can I bring a field to the conference to
say look this is what a field is a bunch
of vectors you know I'm you say that's
that's what those aren't vectors by the
way with magnitude and direction that's
all the earth and no you can't you can't
bring you know vector I cannot bring a
vector to you so are we talking physics
are we talking math and again this is
something you've got to keep in mind all
the time
okay here you have different kinds of
again fields and the important thing I
want to show here and look at this see
look at the arrows look at the arrows
this is important they go into the South
Pole and out the north in all cases okay
so no matter what magnet you get that's
the cow song we presented now this is
convention okay
the lines exist in other words there is
some kind of flow the word is flow but
they don't know what it is and they just
say look we're gonna call the place
where it goes into the magnet will call
that massage place where it comes out
we'll call it the north that's just
convention okay but the point is that
there is some kind of flow of something
whatever it is and it follows these
factors and they have magnitude they get
stronger near the magnet we go away from
yeah that's important to notice okay and
why is this important because I'm gonna
I'll show you how magnet works and show
you that there is a physical
interpretation for us
you don't have to believe my physical
interpretation I'm saying I'm gonna try
to explain this this phenomena you see
there goes into the South Pole out them
yeah here we have to max okay they
attract each other magic so what do we
know let's let's put a field in
so how did the field do it yeah okay so
it's got a feel okay then what do we do
with this have you have you understood
the mechanism how magnet attracts
another by putting the word feel by
putting something around no and
obviously you can't you know you cannot
understand by putting word in fact the
word field hides more than what did you
know it means
remember goes into the south pole up the
north right and here you have the flow
so I'm gonna spend a little time on this
one you're gonna see at the top that
this is a coil yeah you have a coil and
you have the flow of the magnetic field
around the coil a coil that has magnet
because it's electrified or whatever
that's the flow of you know the so
called magnetic field around the coil
and you can superimpose a magnet up on
top of that in the center right and it's
gonna have the same pattern of the field
the fields gonna have the same pattern
as a coil whether it's a man hit or at
once
yeah and I'm saying that looks like you
know when I show there a second ago
you'll see it again
here you can see at the top it goes to
the right it's clockwise and the top
part of the coil would go clockwise the
bottom part ones go counterclockwise
look at the arrows okay if you look at
the arrows it goes into the South Pole
there's the magnet superimposed on it
and out the north that's the pattern
that field of magnetic field leaves
either on a coil or on a magnet and I
put two tanks army tanks and they're
facing each other okay and you know you
you sell those tracks know that go
around and that's essentially the the
flow of what you see in a magnetic field
it's like if you put two tanks one
against each other upside down right and
whereas in the top one you will have
counter clockwise but the bottom one
will have counter clockwise look at the
flow that's the flow of a magnet around
the center of a man okay and out the
other end of South End you know it just
like that so if you look at each one of
the pictures this is a little bit of
brainwashing I'm giving you here okay
but keep in mind this is
the flow overnight that's what's
happening inside of magma and this has
been already tested and verified
whatever so nobody will disagree with
this with the flow okay but that's what
it is and if you look at it that's
that's the flow of the feet something is
moving in there and that's something
it's important to know James Maxwell
said what's in there what is it what is
a field he says there is matter in
motion matter in motion he says I don't
know what it is but there's something
moving in there and the same thing more
or less that was said by Faraday before
him he says you know a magnetic field
I cannot imagine all those lines of
force without some physicality in there
he just didn't accept that that was just
the spirit or whatever he said there's
something there I just don't know what
it is okay and so I'm gonna put
something in there so that you can
visualize the same mechanism we have to
explain this pattern okay we have to
explain the flow right now okay and so
this is what I'm saying it is you take
two guys put them on top of magnitude
two guys put them on the bottom of
magnet they swing their ropes around and
you can see they latch on because
they're both swinging them guys in the
top are swinging their ropes
counterclockwise the two guys on the
bottom they're swinging the ropes
clockwise and those ropes are going
through the center and you can see the
two magnets there you can see the one
that has the south and the north the
threat of the ropes in this case go into
the south end and come out the North
when you put these magnets together you
can see what's happened they latch onto
each other if you look at it's just the
blue part okay let's look at the blue
part only the guy on the top left he's
swinging his rope
counterclockwise and it latches on to
the guy on the right who also swings his
rope counterclockwise look at the guys
on the button they're both making their
ropes clockwise and again the latch on
and pulled each other so I'm saying it's
a very simple mechanism it's just you
know this guy's going like this and the
other guy's going like that it goes into
the South Pole out the north okay and
where if you put North against South you
get this situation where these two are
going on the top are going this way and
the 200 bottom are going that way yeah
okay so so you can see the the pattern
that matches what what we see in magnets
and in coils it's exactly the same
pattern so there's no reason to just say
that this does not at least simulate
what we see the things here we have the
same two little guys on top they're
swinging the ropes now we're going to
rotate the magnet on the Left
upside-down I'm just going to turn them
around you can see there what's
happening and when you turn them upside
down the guy no the left still remains
counterclockwise on top and the bottom
still remains clockwise on the bottom
and you can watch it into a couple
seconds to verify for yourself that that
is the case and that's exactly what we
verify in a minute if you turn a
rectangular magnet if you turn it upside
down it'll still be northagen's up
nothing changes and that's why you can
see it here you see that with the flow
of ropes nothing changes it always
remains counterclockwise at the top five
points on the bottom and what happens
when we turn them now a hundred
eighty-one of the magnets 180 degrees
and we put north again north or south
again stop well we know what happens
they push each other way right and here
it is look see it here we're gonna turn
this guy around 180 degrees behind the
left
there he goes and now now you can see
that the top guy in the top was love
he's clockwise he no longer
counterclockwise and the guy in the
bottom he's no longer than [ __ ] wise now
he's counterclockwise and what they do
they push each other away they swing the
ropes right and they're flashy pushing
each other away okay simple very easy to
understand just
doesn't mean you believe it just means
I've been able to imitate the mechanism
okay so what are the questions that
people ask at this point will they say
well one of those ropes made out of you
know and why did they do this and where
did they come from and you know they've
got all these kinds of questions and the
answer to all those questions the same
it's beyond the scope of this
presentation right now I just want to
show that with this mecha know with
these ropes I can produce attraction and
repulsion in a way that I've just showed
that Illustrated now that's private
particles can you do it with particles I
mean I'll give you all the time you want
you know what are you going to throw the
particles at the other guy how do you
pull a magnet towards another we're
party with the screen particles and you
cannot you cannot even imagine a
mechanism so the only thing that I'm
trying to say today is yeah there you
know we can go into what is a rope made
of what why are they swinging we can go
to all those questions but right now I
just want to concentrate on the
mechanism I've explained a mechanism
with objects I'm saying it's a rope it's
a physical object it's a very tiny
invisible object and you throw swing
around I'm simulating first the field
I run Amanda's first and second
introducing attraction from a distance
and repulsion also from a distance okay
so that's what I'm that's the point of
the presentation today and so here are
the conclusions physics is about
providing you a physical interpretation
to phenomena a physical interpretation
requires an object you do need object
you can't do it with concept you can't
move concepts around mathematical
physics simulates all invisible
phenomenon with concepts that use energy
mass force time field right and
mathematical physics does not have a
physical interpretation for any
phenomenon in which an invisible entity
serves as a medium you will not say that
and of course that's why today we
no explanation we have a description but
we have no explanation for how a magnet
attracts another eye that's it